najwa courtois nage pour toi bonjour je
suis céline monsarrat je suis la voix
française de dori et ce soir c'est
l'avant première du monde de dori
amusez vous bien les enfants ça va
tomber dans les abris oui cory oui à
copse amiens c'est super suite tu as
plus c'était absolument magique c'est
vraiment un super des seins nus et loyal
et j'ai été banni par le film c'était
vraiment super c'était drôle et ça m'a
plu j'ai rigolé d'idées mais c'était
trop m'ignorer une belle morale c'est un
super film c'est chouette c'est super
émouvant ça vachement bien ce que fait
disney autour de la protection des
océans
franchement pour tous les enfants les
parents c'est un très très jolie fille
au rendez vous mercredi dans les salles
pour le monde de dori